these are the raw materials for kovat 19
vaccine bags full of biological cells
seem to have an inactivated or dead
virus added to them turned like butter
in a bioreactor this is one of the most
promising candidates in the global race
for a vaccine
it's made by Cinna vac a biotech company
on the outskirts of Beijing Sky News is
the first British broadcaster to go
inside this lab last month they publish
results in the academic journal science
which showed the vaccine protects
monkeys from infection by the corona
virus and the scientists here are
optimistic that it will protect humans
too this is a research this is
production what clinical trials are
ongoing so Novak is pumping out doses of
the vaccine so that it can be ready if
they succeed they're aiming for a
hundred million doses despite all the
measures taken to contain Koba 19 the
lockdowns the quarantines the track and
trace programs all the hardships endured
by millions the only way after this is
with a vaccine and this is the frontline
of that work and one the best hopes for
all of us at the same time the research
is ongoing the vaccine is currently in
stage 2 human trials with more than a
thousand volunteers they'll run over the
next few months then there'll be stage 3
and after that clinical approval all of
which means the vaccine won't be here
soon they're actually to France has a
production side which they're ramping up
and then there's this which is the
scientific research that still obviously
has to go on while they try and get the
quantities ready if the vaccine is
successful and take it to the public
it is the Kovach 19 vaccine we are
developing and this is we call it
prefilled syringe so when people use it
will be easy they don't have to direct
our so it's a very advanced one the
biggest problem for cinah vac right now
is the low number of coronavirus cases
in China to test the vaccine they have
to look further afield including to the
UK we are speaking to several European
countries and and I think we did discuss
with UK as well but I'm not currently
severe a preliminary stage with the
discussion
it is also our recommendation that it is
not usually the whole population to get
the vaccine in like we are discussing
and recommending to some other countries
as well we firstly targeting on the the
high-risk group we said for example
health workers or the senior citizens
there is a long road ahead and there are
no guarantees for this just might be our
way out
Tom Cheshire Sky News Beijing